what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
we have huge news today that answers a
question that Marvel fans specifically
MCU fans have been wanting to know for a
very long time the answer to the
question who bought the Avengers Tower
from Tony Stark and we were not short on
theories of who could have possibly
bought the Avengers Towers from Tony
Stark could it have been Reed Richards
could he have bought the building and
turned it into the Baxter building the
headquarters for the Fantastic board
could it have possibly been Norman
Osborne who could have possibly turned
it into the Oscorp Tower well according
to a new report today it's something
that we really did not expect at all as
it seems like the demon Mephisto is
actually the one that bought Avengers
Tower from Tony Stark and if this is
true this leads to a lot of questions
however there is a storyline here that
does seemingly make sense of what could
be happening in the MCU and how Mephisto
could be playing a new prominent role
moving forward and this actually sets up
the midnight Suns perfectly if Marvel
Studios is planning on going down a
story route that they did in the comics
we'll see not only the Avengers fighting
Mephisto but also the midnight Suns
fighting Mephisto as well and possibly
even see the Avengers fighting the
midnight Suns not the true Avengers kind
of possessed and slash soulless Avengers
fighting the midnight Suns it's a pretty
epic battle in the comics that goes on
for hours we also have some details
about how Mephisto is connecting to the
Iron Heart Series where it's said by
deadline that this could be the show
where he makes his debut now they've
reported that Sasha barakowen is going
to be in the ironheart series and
deadline believes him to be playing
Mephisto this has also been reported on
by other insiders as well and it's also
been reported that Mephisto is going to
be able to take many different forms in
the MCU meaning we're not always going
to see him as Sasha Bara Cohen and when
we do see a massage barricone we could
see him as a demon the Red Devil that he
is or we could see him in human form in
businessman form or it's even possible
that Aubry Plaza could also be playing a
version of Mephisto as well in Agatha
coven of chaos it's been said that she
is going to be playing an insanely
powerful character one that is an
ancient character and stronger than the
Scarlet Witch so what exactly is the
plan here for Mephisto now yesterday we
had a lot of tweets come out about
Mephisto from Insider's my time to shine
hello can we get some toast and the
cosmic circus it started off with can we
get some toast tweeting that the hood is
stealing tech for Mephisto in ironheart
the question is why then after that we
got a response to that tweet from my
time to shine hello stating that
Mephisto in his human form owns a tech
company so the hood is stealing tech for
Mephisto who apparently in our real
world owns a tech company then the
cosmic circus.com came out with an
article stating that Tony Stark made a
deal with the devil for The Avengers
Tower Cosmic circus and the article
written by Alex Perez confirms that
their sources have told them that
Mephisto is indeed the one who bought
the Avengers tower now right away let's
back up and talk about the fact that
Tony Stark sold it to Mephisto I don't
personally believe that he knew who
mephista was because we've learned some
new details about Mephisto and that is
that he is primarily going to be
appearing in human form when he gets
introduced in ironheart he is mostly
going to be kind of in a business attire
he's going to look like a businessman
he's going to look like this businessman
who owns a huge tech company it's
obviously big enough for him to purchase
the old Avengers Tower so that is
primarily how we're going to see him
however we have heard that he will
appear at least once in his demon form
in the ironheart series which makes
sense you're introducing a new character
that a lot of casual Marvel fans are
just casual moviegoers are going to go
oh who is this new business tycoon
person and then tease him with oh he's
actually this other being he could be
the devil he could be a demon he could
simply be a powerful sorcerer but
clearly he is much bigger than just a
businessman and I believe that's how he
appeared with Tony Stark he appeared as
simply a normal businessman who had the
means to purchase the tower from Tony
Stark and at that time Tony Stark either
already had the other Avengers HQ built
or he already had plans to do it which
is why he sold the tower Tony Stark most
likely just saw another businessman and
since he was trying to sell the tower he
was more than likely just happy to sell
it or it could have actually been pepper
pots who met with him we know that she
was running Stark Industries and maybe
she was the one who executed this deal
and in that case I definitely don't
think she knew who it was now as far as
what story could possibly be happening
here in the MCU well we could be going
with the damnation storyline and this is
a very interesting storyline that I
don't think they're going to adapt page
for page in the MCU for one they don't
ever really do that they just draw
inspiration from the story and and two I
think the exact story might be pretty
dark maybe too dark for the MCU however
we are diving into that darker side of
the MCU we dove into it in the
Multiverse of Madness and it looks like
Marvel Studios is going to double down
on that dark side with Mephisto entering
the MCU because in the damnation
storyline in the comics we basically see
Las Vegas go to hell like literally go
to the hell dimension in which Mephisto
is in charge Las Vegas basically gets
destroyed due to Hydra and then Doctor
Strange attempts to bring it back and
revert the damage that was caused but in
doing that a huge building popped out of
nowhere called Hotel Inferno when
strange went to check it out he found
out that Mephisto was running it and
that actually Las Vegas had kind of
manifested itself in hell so when
strange pulled it back he kind of pulled
hell back with it and the hotel ended up
having a really big effect on the people
of Las Vegas basically making them act
on Instinct and impulse having no
control over their actions and it
basically made them a sin in which
Mephisto would take their souls and
what's even more interesting is that it
engulfed the present Avengers Falcon
Captain Marvel 4 Hawkeye and black
panther and he turned them into ghost
writers almost soulless beings that
would basically do the will of Mephisto
it's a big long story that happens but
essentially Wong ends up calling the
midnight Sons to come in and help
strange gets captured and eventually
they end up tricking Mephisto with
Johnny Blaze what happens is Mephisto
ends up coming to Earth out of the hell
Dimension and Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider
goes into the hell Dimension and
essentially takes the throne making
Mephisto have considerably less power
than he did so the Avengers and all of
the other Heroes like the midnight Suns
end up locking Mephisto at the top of
the hotel it remains in Las Vegas but
Mephisto is trapped by Magic and that
could be kind of the story route that
Marvel Studios may be going don't forget
that in the She-Hulk series Madison who
would become a friend of wogs stated
that she went to some hell Dimension and
made a deal with a goat and if she
didn't basically pull through he would
get her soul while Mephisto has been a
goat in the comics before so this does
kind of seem like a setup also they did
tease us with Donny blaze in that show
as well not Johnny Blaze the true Ghost
Rider but Donnie Blaze seemingly another
setup for Ghost Rider to enter which
could mean that the midnight suns are
about to enter as well and if we truly
are going to make Mephisto a focus of
the dark side of the MCU which I do
think is an excellent idea to have him
be one of the big bads of the universe
then things are definitely going to get
darker really soon and they're going to
need a dark team to take on all of these
Supernatural threats which makes the
midnight Suns the perfect team to come
into the MCU we already have a ton of
them set up like Dr Strange Moon Knight
Daredevils coming into play the
punishers come in as well Deadpool is
coming we have a lot and there could be
a lot more coming like blade and
hopefully Ghost Rider comes pretty soon
as well but this is going to be
considerably darker considerably more
grown up but sounds like it's going to
be one crazy cool cool story so let us
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below also don't
forget to like the video and if you
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month we're also on patreon now
we also have a full functioning website
that we post to every day and we have a
Discord server we'll link all of those
in the pin comment and the description
below you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
beep